are unpaid internships a waste of time
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
nabila who wrote in to ask a question
hey evan awesome video your channel has
some helpful videos
and points something i notice you say a
lot is getting started and get out there
which i personally feel is the best type
of advice
this is because for me i can be very
unmotivated and just want something to
happen my question for you is
how do you feel about obtaining an
internship in order to learn
more about a specific field how things
get done etc
so you can apply it to your own future
company more specifically
how do you feel about unpaid internship
positions
do you think is beneficial or a waste of
time
this is a great question in my view
the only reason to take a job is to
learn
you're working for somebody else to
learn so the main objective here of
taking an internship or a job
is not to make a lot of money but to
learn now i have an entire
zuga guide that walks you through this
whole process but i'm going to do my
best
to crunch this down into one video for
you
the important thing to remember here is
you know you have to survive
you have to have enough money to you
know if you're paying rent
i don't want you to live on the street
and be homeless i don't want you to
not be able to eat so you know money at
some point becomes an issue
if you're going unpaid or even low paid
internship
but your main goal here is to learn
that's your main objective are you going
to learn at this company
or not so i don't know what kind of
business that you want to start
but let's say you want to start a
fashion company so you want to start
making dresses
if you went out and you had zero
experience you said okay i'm going to
make a dress company and just start
and you're invested into machines and
the staff and the location
you're probably going to go broke you're
going to invest all this
energy time dollars into something that
because you don't have any experience
you're going to make a ton of mistakes
and lose everything and i don't want
that for you the better path
is to go find a company that has 10
employees not a huge company but a
smaller company
who's built up to a certain size is a
company you respect and look up to
and where you can learn from and take a
job
it could be an internship it could be a
part-time job it could be a volunteer
paid unpaid whatever it is
there's a few reasons why it's so
important okay the first one is
to see if this is even something that
you want to do
a lot of times you get ideas i get ideas
i'm going to try this out i have this
vision for this thing i want to create
and then you start into something
and it's not what you thought it was you
know you may get into it you may say i
want to make dresses i love dresses
i'm going to start into the dress
business you'll get this job at a dress
company and realize wow this is a
i hate this industry i don't want to be
here
and so that saves you a lot of grief and
agony because you figure that out
working for somebody else instead of
working
you know for yourself and losing a ton
of money and time on it so that's the
first thing it does the second thing is
it teaches you
about the industry it teaches you so
that you don't make mistakes
it teaches you so that when you're ready
to go and launch your own business you
have contacts you have experience you
know what you're doing
like if you went to university right you
paid to go to university you pay to go
to college
here you're either volunteering your
times you're not paying anything
or you're getting paid maybe not a lot
but a little bit you're getting paid to
learn
right university you have to work you
have to work hard right to get your
grades
you're gonna have to work hard at this
company but you're working to learn
and it's cheaper than a university
education so that when you are ready to
go
do your own business you know what
you're doing you've already made your
mistakes
the reason why it's important started a
small company not not the biggest
companies in the field
is because there's lots of opportunities
to learn
in a smaller company right at a big
company you do an unpaid internship you
might be doing a lot of photocopying
getting coffee for people you're not
learning right it may be something
that's great for your resume to say hey
i worked at this huge company
but if your eventual goal is to start
your own business your resume doesn't
matter
you want to learn so a smaller company
10 15 employees
if you can get close to the entrepreneur
they need help
entrepreneurs we need help okay
entrepreneurs never say oh i've got too
much time on my hands right there's
always so much on the go
that you might be hired or brought on
board as a free intern to do one
specific thing
you'll almost always find if you can get
close to the entrepreneur there'll be
more opportunities that open up
entrepreneurs love seeing hard-working
people there
there there aren't too many
entrepreneurs who say yeah all of my
team they're highly motivated they're
super hard working i love all of them
they're they're all fantastic
right there's always there's always room
for great employees for great workers at
companies
so if they see that you're doing a great
job they're going to give you more and
more and more and more and you want that
even if you're not getting paid because
you're
the education is what you're paying for
right your goal isn't to be there
working for free for the next 20 years
your goal is to learn about the business
and then go do your own thing
right if you need more time there they
may they may find that you are
you know your goals will be
indispensable to them and they may offer
you a job and they may give you raises
and you have to decide okay well do i
am i still learning here do i want to
take this job that maybe started off for
free
and i'm getting paid to do it or don't
want to go on am i ready to launch my
own company
you have to make that decision at that
time but make yourself
indispensable to the entrepreneur you're
working with
learn from them they'll keep giving you
new projects
hopefully they give you some more money
but the whole point is not about the
cash
it's the experience so that you can
build a highly successful company
yourself believe for those who watching
like the video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think what are your
thoughts on internships paid and unpaid
if you've hired people or had people
come on as interns
let me know leave it in the comments
below you have a question
put it below make a video response and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
by clicking on my face
if you want to see more videos like this
thank you so much and i'll see you soon
uh a lost my flow there
so but down to down just dance
it'll come back it'll come back it'll
come back
you